was with great action here rolls come
great action figures ladies and
gentlemen and we've got some here here
oh no you dropped your hammer
so there's yours have you seen it yet uh
not that particular one but it's the
likenesses incredible it is one canny
isn't it ladies and gentlemen it's
wicked slightly sedated version and then
you do it all thing you press you hear
and you talk strike you down he's angry
there's you and then we'll just get
nataly's action figure here she's now
they are almost children with hours fun
playing with those
they're gonna have a great time
are you coming with those dolls that's
not a hammer
but you look a bit too strong I think
your hanger desert
hey but you're not the only two people
to be dolls no no no no look it's it
well it don't quite an action figure but
it's it is
she's right now I think all the work
went into the face not so much into the
outfit it's him on oh just an off day
yeah it's like care in the community
we've dressed him you see the carny just
pottering around Homebase packaging not
great it's in a sort of ziplock we never
didn't think the but look there's a nice
there's a nice sensible shoe we were
driving a long distance is it for sale
doll
I think we've water didn't we yeah we
bought this it's a lady immense them
it's a little sideline of my auntie
Valerie
they took us in through the back door
story of our life